bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
cyclisme sur piste l'équipe de france a
remporté sept médailles dont trois en or
à l'occasion des championnats d'europe
qui se sont tenues au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la semaine
dernière nous reviendrons sur le bilan
tricolore dans cette émission
handball versailles s'impose enfin à
domicile cette saison ce samedi 22
octobre les bleus et roses ont dominé 5
pro l'aumône dans leur gymnase moment à
l'occasion de la 6e journée du
championnat de prénationale et
versailles et se sont imposés 34 à 24 et
remonte au classement plus
d'informations à suivre
karting l'actuel champion de france de
mini carte gim il ya ce huit ans n'a pas
réussi à remporter les championnats du
monde de la catégorie sur le circuit
international de sarnaut en italie le
pilote celui en courtois été disqualifié
de la croupe ce revers trop haute
nous reviendrons sur cet épisode avec
lui dans cette émission gros plan à
présent sur les principaux résultats du
week-end
on commence tout de suite ce magazine
par les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste la compétition s'est
terminée à ce dimanche au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
après cinq jours de course
la france a emporté à sept médailles
dont trois en or grâce à la révélation
trappistes benjamin thomas à 21 ans le
montage a signé à sandrine frontalière
les championnats d'europe de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juste terminée
l'heure est au bilan pour l'équipe de
france les tricolores ont réussi à
séduire le public du vélodrome nationale
après le fiasco des jo de rio l'été
dernier les pistes a remporté sept
médailles noteront lors avec une équipe
rajeunie au delà du bilan des médailles
c'est sur toi à bilange l'équipe d'état
d'esprit avec des jeunes avec une
génération que l'on souhaite accompagner
et derrière une émulation qui s'est créé
une équipe qui vit ensemble et qui vit
bien ensemble
plus que le paris des médailles et on se
rend compte que ben y en a qui sont déjà
au rendez vous
effectivement on en veut toujours plus
un moment donné mais je pense que sur
cette année post olympique avec les
profils qu'on souhaite cibler pour
préparer l'avenir
c'est un très beau bilan on peut
toujours faire mieux
on est sur un championnat d'europe on
est avec la jeune génération
c'est un travail de long terme on peut
peut-être faire mieux on a déjà fait un
très bon résultat
le saint quentinois quentin lafargue a
profité de la mise à l'écart de françois
pervis de grégory baugé pour s'imposer
en leader de cette équipe de france à
seulement 25 ans le pistard raflé la
médaille d'or sur le km en devançant de
deux dixièmes l'allemand eric anglaise
c'est très important
et ouais je suis très très très contente
pour le par rapport au travail que j'ai
pu faire je suis un coéquipier qui se
font dans une équipe de france qui est
en train de se recréer
je suis du coup bas j'étais plus jeune
l'année dernière j'ai un nez plus dans
ce sens l'année
et ben voilà j'ai un petit peu
d'expérience mais je me propose pas en
leader je prépare mes objectifs et
j'essaie d'être le plus performant
possible
la médaille la plus prometteuse a été
remporté par l'équipe de poursuite par
équipe emmenée par l'expérimenté sylvain
chavanel 37 ans et le trappistes
benjamin thomas 21 ans le saint
quentinois également remporté le bronze
sur l'omnium et l'argent sur
l'américaine avec morgan kneisky
j'habite à à cinq kilomètres du
vélodrome donc la piste on la connaît
par coeur on s'entraîne à moi je
m'entraîne tout temps ici donc c'est
vrai que ça fait plaisir
ma famille qui étaient ici ma copine et
où donc c'est top
charlie conord et lui la belle surprise
de cette semaine saint-quentinoise
l'ancien champion du monde junior 2008
s'est rassuré après plusieurs années
compliquées en remportant la médaille de
bronze sur le keirin
ça fait un moment que je courais sur ses
podiums et sur ses médailles au niveau
international soit jusqu'à maintenant ça
va être qu'un début et que tout se
passera pour le mieux sur le soudan son
ratio de la saison l'année prochaine les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste se tiendront à berlin en allemagne
les pistards français reprendront la
compétition le 4 novembre à glasgow pour
l'ouverture de la coupe du monde
on continue ce magazine par du handball
et le championnat de prénationale à
masculine versailles s'est imposé ce
week-end contre saint-ouen l'aumône à
l'occasion de la 6e journée de la
division
les versaillais sans trembler longtemps
porté à 34 à 24 et se relance dans la
course à la montée les images sont
signés camille lambert
merci s'impose enfin domicile cette
saison ce samedi 22 octobre les bleus et
roses aux dominés saint-ouen l'aumône
dans leur gymnase bonbons à l'occasion
de la 6e journée du championnat de
prénationale après une grosse première
période remportée c'est à dix les
versaillais ont accentué leur avance
pour s'imposer 34 à 24
sur le match on a dominé le début je
pense que surtout en défense on a
beaucoup montré beaucoup d'envié du coup
les gardoises ont fait beaucoup d'arrêts
par rapport à nos matches précédents
et c'est là dessus qu'on a gagné le
match et après on est forcément
défendant bien en bas ça ça nous fait
récupérer les ballons joués jeu rapide
la force si attentionnés c'est que les
joueurs avaient vraiment envie de gagner
ont écouté mes consignes du début à la
fin on l'avait un peu le jeu
sur la première mi temps sera très
limité en fonction du changement de côté
de terrain et des changements défense et
qu'on pouvait avoir aidé voir qu'on
avait le plan de jeu a été respecté on
avait dossier de défense possible à 0
sont à 5 avec des joueurs différents
on a alterné beaucoup pour que tout
soufflé et qu'on puisse maintenir un
rythme sur le jeu rapide
cette victoire permet à versailles de
mettre fin à une série de quatre
défaites consécutives et de remonter au
classement et jour d'alexandre taillefer
occupe désormais la septième place à
huit points du leader plaisir espère
toujours monter cette saison nos
objectifs elle était la montée
la problématique c'est qu'heuliez à
trois clubs le métro
rudd et plaisir qu'ils sont également
renforcés donc la montée on savait je
l'avais dit au groupe allait être
beaucoup plus dur cette année que
l'année dernière elle s'avère on a eu
des joueurs blessés en début de saison
des absents pour diverses raisons
travail vacances ce qui nous a fait
qu'on a été à jouer même jusqu'à même
pas en plus à une fin de match à 12 le
week-end dernier
une fois qu'on sera maintenu on verra si
on peut se placer le plus haut possible
pour continuer à attirer des joueurs
pourraient éventuellement augmenter
l'année prochaine
prochain match pour les versets et le
samedi 12 novembre contre brunoy à
l'extérieur une équipe à égalité de
points avec les joueurs de la cité
royale
le spectacle n'était pas que sur le
terrain les tribunes gymnase mont boron
également à vibrer pour la rencontre
avec les ultras à royal blue le groupe
de supporters fêté ce samedi son
quatrième anniversaire lancé en octobre
2012 les tifosi compose aujourd'hui
d'une trentaine de fans soutiennent les
joueurs du versailles handball club à
domicile comme à l'extérieur avec des
chants des drapeaux l'étambot notre
journaliste camille lambert a rencontré
le cofondateur à des ultras adversaire
tout début c'était nos coachs quand il y
en a beaucoup qui joue rendent en groupe
et quand on a commencé à jouer au rang
de nos coachs jouer en équipe senior et
donc on allait au début les voir rejouer
et
on a bien aimé puis à notre âge c'est
sympa de se retrouver entre potes de
chanter entre nous c'est des bons
souvenirs on ouvre à présent une page
coupe de france ce week end noir pour
les club yvelinois
les quatre équipes du département encore
engagés dans la compétition ont tous
perdus à l'extérieur versailles s'est
incliné à 2 à 1 contre blanc mesnil qui
évolue pourtant dans la même division
que les versaillais
les joueurs de la cité royale ont fini à
dix et ont raté un penalty de son côté
mante a perdu 2 0 contre viry châtillon
les clés sous ion réussi l'exploit de
sortir à les mureaux les yvelinois
évolue pourtant trois divisions
au-dessus de leurs adversaires
enfin bobigny a terrassé poissy à 2 0
les yvelinois en 2015 avait réussi à
hisser un club en 16e de finale menthe
avait éliminé par nantes à domicile
une fois n est pas coutume nous allons
parler de tir à l'arc dans ce magazine
une compétition de tir à 18 mètres en
salle était programmé pendant deux jours
au complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
à montigny-le-bretonneux
comme tous les ans le tournoi était
organisé par la compagnie de tir à l'arc
de la ville qui compte plus de 125
adhérents pendant deux jours plus de 2
120 archers ont participé à ce rendez
vous on écoute l'un des organisateurs
philippe pommier le président du club
il revient sur le niveau de la
compétition la compétition salle ne fait
que commencer il ya ça a commencé dans
78 ya quinze jours c'était à trappes
la semaine dernière c'était à buc
donc les archers ils sont pas encore
dans la lah de la plate forme retenant
ce petit à petit le tir en salle de
manière à être performant pour le mois
de février mars
nauru va y avoir début mars ferrals
championnat départemental salins trappe
après il ya un championnat régional puis
après l'achat championnat de france un
bond de gens et ils s'entraînent petit à
petit devenir avocat
la meilleure performance chez les
seniors dames arc classique nathalie
ville mode d'antonia remporté à la
compétition avec un score de 521 la know
more pas jan karol pingaud a quant à
elle terminé troisième chez les hommes
guillaume blairon a raflé la première
place avec un total de 550 de serre 600
possibles
le premier saint quentinois simon belle
se termine 4e tous les résultats sont à
retrouver sur le site qui s'affiche à
l'écran de la compagnie d'arc de
montigny direction à présent les
terrains de rugby tout va bien pour le
sky dans le championnat de promotion
d'honneur
les saint quentinois se sont facilement
imposés contre marcoussis lors du
dernier match 45 à 10 au classement le
sky est premier avec trois victoires en
trois matches et 14 points engrangés
nous avons interrogé à thomas p rien sur
le début de saison au canon de son
équipe
c'est dans la continuité de la saison
dernière où on a fait une grosse grosse
saison on a perdu plus de matches
donc il ya une grosse grosse préparation
cet été beaucoup de physique beaucoup de
jeux avec ballons également c'est assez
lourd pour les joueurs mais du coup
c'est payant d'entrée de saison on n'a
pas encore joué les meilleures équipes
de la poule je pense du coup pour nous
c'est une bonne entrée en matière ça
nous permet de rentrer progressivement
dans le championnat course automobile
l'actuel champion de france de mini kart
jimmy il ya huit ans n'a pas réussi à
remporter les championnats du monde de
la catégorie sur le circuit
international de sarnaut en italie le
pilote du en courtois a été disqualifié
à 2 la course nous avons la chance de
recevoir sur ce plateau
jimmy elias et son père cyrille qui est
également son coach on peut le dire
aussi vous êtes également une histoire
hors du nid alors on va tout de suite
revenir sur cette disqualification cyril
pourquoi j'ai mis a été disqualifiée
alors suite à un entraînement donc en
essais libres
l'accord du mondial a duré une semaine
bon le règlement et des est en anglais
mais on n'y a pas d' excuses j'ai changé
donc une laine d'échappement qui était
une haine qui était pas neuf et
donc c'est interdit par le règlement
j'aurais vraiment pensé que c'était
vraiment comme on fait toute l'année que
pendant les manches qualifs les essais
chronos ou des manches officielles où il
ya quelque chose à gagner
et tel n'a pas été le cas donc
disqualifiée malheureusement par la
faute de son papa pour les championnats
du monde or que jimmy a nous a fait à la
dernière ce dernière série défi libre le
deuxième temps absolu à trois millièmes
du meilleur temps donc c'est vraiment
triste
jimmy tu n'en veux pas trop à ton papa
de d'avoir fait cette petite bourde non
pas du tout et qui et quels sentiments
tu as eue quand tu as été disqualifié
j'étais triste et tu comprenais pourquoi
non pas du tout et quand on voit les
autres pilotes pouvoir concourir
tu l'as pas réussi du coup à concourir
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça t'a fait
jouer les gagne le championnat du monde
j'ai parlé ici ce que va pas il a fait
une erreur et comment avez vous géré
gimmick justement après cette annonce ça
n'a pas été facile
il vient juste d'avoir huit ans c'était
le bon déjà il y avait un pays d'arnoult
la france ont été avec l'équipe de
france
maintenant c'est vrai que ça a été
vraiment intransigeant
j'aurais pensé que l'erreur est humaine
on essaie libre où il n'y a rien à
gagner
je veux dire c'est pas on n'a pas fait
les choses volontairement pour vouloir y
avait rien à gagner
c'était vraiment des essais libres
maintenant jimmy pour le gérer ça n'a
pas été facile il était en pleurs après
l'annnonce de sa disqualification de
plus qu'il a vu qu'ils avaient le niveau
international pour jouer la gagne
il avait une chance une réelle chance de
rien changé à la victoire contre jimmy à
la dernière séance d'essai libre fait le
deuxième temps avec tous les meilleurs
pilotes mondiaux hors taxes à trois
millièmes derrien portugais et devant
l'américain qui champion du monde
aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment triste
malgré son jeune âge je pense vraiment
qu'il avait toutes les chances de se
battre sur pour le podium et après selon
le déroulement de la course des
champions jimmy qu'est ce que tu as
pensé de ta compétition
ça s'est bien passé
oui en dehors de ce petit problème ben
oui mais je voulais gagner si triste
les autres pilotes qui quiconque ouvrir
face à lui été impressionné vraiment par
jimmy les parents elle était
impressionnée par jour je pense que
jimmy a eu effectivement dès qu'on
arrivait on avait un petit souci le kart
était beaucoup trop grand pour 10 me les
tailles les plus kitai deux baquets
était trop grande pour jimmy on a du
coup on a dû avoir une dérogation pour
avoir un petit bac es par le patron de
chez rotax
et c'est incroyable parce que si vous
voulez au bout de quelques séries quand
jamie a fait le deuxième meilleur temps
de flux des concurrents se sont plaints
pour demander à ce qu'on change le bac
est donc ils nous ont fait changer un
baquet ou 10000 e bac était beaucoup
trop grand et c'était vraiment difficile
pour lui de pouvoir conduire dans ces
conditions c'est de cette façon là et
donc effectivement il a fait peur à
beaucoup de monde
je pense qu'ils ont vu qu'il y avait un
réel talent et qu'il avait une vraie
vraie possibilité de gagner
merci à tous les deux dépassé sur ce
plateau jimmy on souhaite bon courage
pour la suite de ta carrière elle ne
fait que débuter et les
contre-performances arrive et je pense
que vous allez réussir à le re mobiliser
merci nous avoir suivis cette émission
est terminée rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là pas scéniques semaine sportive très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78